oh yes yes please applause
thank you my money's on Susan by the way
if you're duking it out but so boy I
okay my name's Ben whee-hee I'll start
there I work at that MIT Museum and my
title my job title is manager of the
Science Festival Alliance that's been my
job title since 2009
it's hard to I kind of want to like just
cede my time to Lou because you know I
found a fantastic to listen her I have
deep respect for who have worked see you
know I've been adjacent to her for a
while now
and she knows things and I don't know
that I'm not sure that's why I was asked
to stand in front of you because when
when Lou speaks about this you know she
has answers for your questions and I
think I'm just here to be sort of like
the curmudgeon who says it's a hot mess
don't do it so I have like four
different versions of what I was going
to say I've really struggled with this
because it's sort of been my life for
quite a while to be near the center of
gravity of something that looks like I
wouldn't call it community practice it's
called the science festival Alliance we
were intentional with that name so so I
have either not much to say or just way
too much
quick quick so basically I have come
down to just like well then I'll just
make it all about me so I'm gonna just
tell you a little bit about my
trajectory as the science Alliance
manager my perspective on the
practicalities which i think is like the
code for like the hard parts and the
messy parts so the science festival line
started as a with an NSF grant so we
came out of the gates with a concept
that was around a particular format of a
festival for the I'm not going to get
into what festivals are etc they're up
for by the community they massive
celebrations regional celebrations of
science if you've ever
into any festival think of that not make
it for science we had some we had this
clear format we had a three million
dollar grant we had the structure was
already there who was going to be
working on this they we had somebody
with a job title that was supposedly
gonna manage the Alliance part we had
these guiding principles but they
weren't very prescriptive it was meant
to be open-ended you know every
community needs to figure out what it is
to celebrate science so it wasn't about
stamping out a product we had multiple
full-time equivalents working on the
project at four different institutions
we had big travel budgets and meeting
budgets even with all of this I remember
being I just feeling so under-resourced
which sounds ridiculous you know three
million dollars and all these people
working on these incredible institutions
with advocates at the highest echelons
of science but we've assembled we
quickly assemble the machine to get
three festivals up and running
Philadelphia San Diego San Francisco but
others were already wanting in or at
least they thought they did they're kind
of in some we still have this challenge
of like we're not science fairs were
science festivals that was like even
that is where we should were starting
those early years were all consuming
that's a phrase I was like well if I was
to sum it up is all consuming I just
through I felt like we had a very brief
window of opportunity we had the
potential of this attention seizing a
moment we had this three-year grant
I was hired six months and it had
already bled out six months fou and I
was hired and ostensibly the things
started so I and a few others just threw
ourselves completely into this in a
frenzy and I remember thinking this is
insane why am I at the White House right
now what is that what is happening and
but we're building something and once
it's built then we're gonna have this
thing and we're gonna be able to do so
many exciting things with it
so at the end of three years we had done
something right we had we had something
like a dozen festivals that we could
count as sort
being in the fold whatever that meant we
had done our best to maximize attention
we had you know like New York Times
coverage USA Today we had incredible
images from the festivals so we had this
like we're posit Ori to help tell our
story we had eyebrow-raising evaluation
results and we had eye watering
anecdotes just the most touching moving
passionate stories and we had zeal we
really zealots about this but even with
all that like suddenly I'm faced with
like the most uncertain time where the
festival is going to continue to be of
interest what was going on is this just
some like weird passing fad would the
best support for them be to like really
poor effort into like building on a
network or community practice or
whatever whatever but is this thing -
and oh by the way that funding clock is
really close to alarm bells going off
meaning and when that goes off the whole
thing just unravels okay so we need to
get yeah so we need to get the funding
who would get that funding where would
it come from and we didn't really talk
about it much but underlying all this
who owns this thing anyways put that
aside don't do with that so 2012 after
all this effort and throwing not just
myself with several people putting all
they had into this it was a very
difficult year well he was supposed to
be crowning like we've done this like
high fives all around there are so many
meetings as we tried to sort out
internally what the science festival
liance was what it should be how to
realistically make the most of its
potential key personnel were leaving
some personalities were proving
problematic and needed to be I'll say
managed out the so hard for I'm kind of
a nice guy I don't know the the I'm not
conflict averse but it's just I you know
I don't want to tell you but yes the the
amazing relationships that we built up
were growing precarious and you know one
little learning point the best
relationships are created under extreme
duress but and we had gone through that
Crucible there but these were people who
are very action-oriented all about
taking action on a grand grand scale
and they all had except for me festivals
of their own turning away like they're
like hey we've got 40,000 people coming
to this location
next Sunday so like sitting down to talk
about what the science festival Alliance
might be and where we might be headed as
a group don't really have time for that
and so your meetings are becoming a
little bit boring and and you know I was
I remember worrying that I was losing
traction as a manager if I even was a
manager and that the whole thing was
really you know it's coming possibly to
loose ends I distinctly remember
thinking and maybe this is a Lube moment
that the problem was at that time our
real constraints were forcing a top-down
approach to issues that would be much
better addressed from the bottom up and
part of that was a draft after a draft
after a draft of a potential NSF bid was
piling up on my desk and we had these
competing visions we tried putting
working committees in place we tried to
I think the uncertainty made some people
anxious enough we try to formalize
things with strategic plans a membership
program but this just led to more items
needing consensus consensus sometimes is
lowest common denominator one person
even went so far as to draft a
constitution that would govern the
Science Festival Alliance I mean we're
just kind of like grasping at these
things I found an old file cabinet on
campus and dragged it physically down
the sidewalk to my office to put next to
my desk which was a door that I had
flipped over on its side in 2009 because
I only had three years here anyways and
through all this the phone calls with
festivals are still going on new
festival organizers are really want to
talk about these conversations that we
had three years ago and the older
festival organizers have completely new
set of issues that they want to talk
about and in the midst of all this I
find myself going to Cairo with state
department funding that
supposed to be generating a Science
Vessel alliance in the Middle East
during the Arab Spring and I'm like what
why did that happen well because you
know because they're there basically I
couldn't let any opportunity go by like
I had to seize everything all right well
we got the NSF grant we asked for three
million they said - so that was a little
bit painful because we worked on this
thing we didn't just put three in
because it was a cap we wanted more at
the same time we got our first major
grant from a private foundation
I hired Julie Foucher and I built her a
desk and similar style to mine because
we only could count on having her for
two years but now things this is all
looks like really good news right I mean
now 2012
well that was painful but boy 2013 this
is gonna be amazing except there's no
excuses the funding clocks even tighter
now and I mean basically it's just like
alright well now it's time to throw
everything I have into this project
again like I was just doing I'm just
gonna up that and I felt like I'd never
been busier we went from 11 festivals to
30 in a year's time and we put a real
membership thing in place it was light
and I don't know if it makes everybody
happy but we have it the the new members
have like a really different needs than
the old guard of festivals have been
around for a holy two or three years and
we had staff at eight institutions
around the country remunerated in some
way to work on this network which you
think is incredible it really was so
heartening to see people do this
especially because like ask the you know
I'm just gonna do that aerco thing sorry
manager of this that I was my job title
mmm but I mean none of these people
actually reported to me or to anyone
else that was responsible in some way
for the project so soft power is all I
had and I don't know that that could
even be call it that so as things grow
at this crazy pace it layers up
different expectations of how I should
be spending my time I had to go silent
on some relationships simply out of like
saying like I have to rely on that to be
there and soon I had people saying what
do you even do anymore I'm like I've
been so busy that's why we haven't
talked but I realized that I was not you
know not documenting sufficiently not
getting you know there there's these
these shortfalls s it just piled up and
became overwhelming and now we're like 8
million dollars later going into our
10th year and we've involved we've
evolved in so many ways and festivals
like I don't have to explain that
they're not science fairs anymore I mean
we achieved that and the things that
I've seen like and now my burden is in
part like I want to grab everybody by
the lapels Amelia do you know what's
happened out there because we haven't as
much as we've tried to capture it it we
never really you know can convey this
heart moving experiences that are
happening in communities across the
United States and it seems like we've
you know we we recently had a just last
weekend had a lunch with a couple people
and we were just congratulating
ourselves rightly so because just kind
of tried to take a moment to do that and
we'll eat later that afternoon I got
some my phone's ringing right now but
like later that afternoon like I got
these I got a couple emails from two
festivals that were like worried about
the the behavior of another festival and
the next day I had two financial reports
due and those are now overdue and I also
was laying out the application process
to bring 12 new festivals into the
network and I just like wow we're I'm
right back where I remember thinking to
myself
I'm at this spot I've got like two or
three years of funding right now and I
just need to throw everything I have
into this next window of opportunity
where like because now is the time when
like that these things are we're gonna
build something at the end of this three
years it's gonna be so incredible so I
think I'll just leave it at that
that's a practice oh I've been I'm you
know I you know I know you I know you
know I you've watched this insanity so
one of the things that just sounds so
familiar and I'm sure it is the genie
and a bunch of people is like where we
have good examples of communities of
practice or organizations it often feels
like there is one or a small number of
individuals who are basically like
burning the candle at six ends and
they're soon gonna drop down and have a
heart attack or in practice what
actually happens is my doctor says flu
cuz I three-year-olds really heavy and
it's like muscle it's not my heart
yep so I'm okay my doctor just laughs um
but so in fact people don't have heart
attacks people as you said they leave
because it's totally dynamic yeah always
changing um so I guess pop partly for
you partly for lewd like what happens
when people suddenly decide they don't
want to die it 34 from well I'm not so
my I'm pretty okay with like putting my
ego aside on this like I don't think
that I'm the essential ingredient that
makes all anything happen as I say all
this not only just anything at all but
there are key moments in the development
of this where I felt okay I like my job
I just want to say that I do and and I'm
really I love the experience that I've
had over the past 10 years with this
project and there are other projects
that I also work on which is you know
that's another thing is that many of the
people involved in this that are you're
totally depending on it's completely not
their job at all but I definitely have
felt like there are many many moments
where I felt like trapped a little bit
not trapped in uh like I want to get out
but like oh if I did want to get out I'm
not sure I could without things kind of
feeling like they might implode a little
bit I don't know how to reinforce that
we've put together these you know at
various times when the anxiety built and
was really palpable we put together
different kinds of structures to deal
with it at that moment most recently
there was a Science Festival Lions
Council and I thought if I call it a
council not a committee it would feel
like something that you know had more
responsibility and people are
enthusiastic about it but it's sort of
like you know it served a purpose for a
couple years and then like we had our
summit in this past you and we decided
yeah we don't really need to meet the
council that you know I think we did
that served its purpose so I you just
kind of like create organs
small structures for the demands of the
moment and the demands at the moment can
be really fleeting I'm glad we didn't
adopt the Constitution essentially if
you do end up successfully building a
community the idea is that the roles and
responsibilities are shared you know if
we actually build this together no one
person ought to be the weakest link and
we think about this a lot from the
perspective of community management so I
didn't mention this in my talk but after
you know when we set up these
communities there is somebody who is
designated in that role of coalescing
folks together greasing the wheels
ensuring you know that we remember to
reconvene that we do the things that we
do and that role evolves over time you
know if you're your community is healthy
and it's actually progressing through a
life cycle and through two stages of
maturity then the pressure should ease
on that community manager and yes
they're still doing a job but everything
should you know the success or failure
of that community should not depend on
the people convening it solely and
another thing that this gets out I just
also want us to bear in mind is echoes
what Jeanie was saying earlier about
acknowledging all the support staff that
makes things happen this this role of
convening communities is a is an
invisible leadership role right it's not
about one person or a group of people
standing up and saying hey here's what I
think we should do and we're gonna be
the ones that make sure it all gets done
all the time and so you know everybody
being aware of the fact that there there
is value being created there even if
this is not leadership in a very
front-and-center way I think is
important it's maybe might be helpful to
point out that I don't I mean I do often
times quip that I don't do anything and
by that I mean I don't actually organize
a festival of myself I don't have skin
in that game my job is to not like some
godlike figure but like pull myself up
out and look over cut across the
landscape so I have some feeling for
where the center of gravity of the group
be and I can look after those that like
aren't maybe aren't don't have the same
power in the in the community has okay
tell the same story I know this story
well hi I'm Kirk I get that it was hard
I know it was hard because I was in some
of those stories who are telling I get
that it was really hard was it worth it
yeah absolutely I mean it's worth it
even in the even at moments when I
thought it was all gonna collapse
because of something some foolish thing
that I had neglected I still worth it
yeah absolutely I mean it's it really
helps that we all work in a field that
is so inspiring I mean it's just
inspiring the product our product is
inspiring if it's it ought to be and so
that really helps I mean the festivals
are absolutely amazing
and the thing that yeah so I could talk
about that I think that that's in the
end like I mean it's just there's this
like infinite wellspring of passion for
just keeping this going and spreading it
because it's so inspiring to me it's not
a question it's probably not a comment
but it just made the feelings that I was
getting in the last even deeper most of
us are working in much smaller programs
and of how this this weekend of great
gorgeous programs they will all die when
the guy who
a women is doing it we'll leave they
can't even have advice person to do it
because they don't have funding they put
their heart and soul into it
and as soon as they leave it will die in
your story which is a great success
story it's just making it even more
apparent is it if you don't have an
organization of 12 people and you don't
have funding and you put in your summer
salary into doing the summer camp it's
gonna die when you live and how how do
we make it sustainable I've got so many
problems that were just well I mean
partly it is also just sort of isn't the
also the nature of everything that we do
is is just very fleeting like I mean the
ended and dynamic isn't like it this
work it just never will never end is
another way to flip that around
well the festivals I mean we've been
very lucky but the festival is not
exactly brick-and-mortar they can just
did not a year goes by when I'm not
having a crisis conversation with some
festival organizer about like I don't
know if how we're gonna do it this year
so I it I think there's something about
like this for example this meeting I
know a lot of people are here I've met a
lot of people I've had a lot of
inspiring conversations and great
conversations here I there's not been
enough time I wish that this will keep
going but at the same time a lot of the
conversations here mirror conversations
I've had at other meanings if this is a
fourth meeting I've been to in two weeks
and and I've seen a lot of people at
this meeting at those other meetings
those other meetings are helpful but
this why would this meet again well
because we continue to have we live in a
dynamic situation with new members can
come and go the issues that the
community's trying to address are going
to continually be evolving so it's it's
sort of like you know I've just coming
to peace with the knowledge that like
I've not a construction worker like I
don't build a building and then go like
right there it is and that's gonna last
there for generations or 35 years
current standard actually but so that we
work in a different like softer are the
product of our work is this softer than
that and it just needs constant
attention so if a program dies I I don't
I
sorry I couldn't hear that
there's there's also part of me that
like is another side to that - sorry -
just like keep finding silver linings or
way that positively is now I'm no longer
a curmudgeon is that the if you look at
our historical I mean if taking a more
historical stance on the world would do
the entire United States a world of good
so looking just a little bit back you
can see first of all you can see
enormous improvement and evolution in
positive directions but you can also
just like talk to a real old timer and
you start to hear like oh yeah that's
just like that thing we did in 1984 and
that thing in there was member that in
the 70s we had this other program that
that was just so amazing and so you know
with the festivals people there's some
people get really fixated on origin
stories especially those who think that
they are the origin and I part of my job
is to poke holes in that ever I actually
it's not my job it's my personality is
its to poke holes in those kinds of that
notion because you know my god where the
science festivals come from who started
this thing and my reply is not meant to
be facetious but like I say I kind of
peg it to like maybe dawn of Agriculture
to put it there comfortably that like
people have been coming together to
celebrate how technology and knowledge
makes them who they are that's let's put
it let's put it you know there's like
World's Fairs and all that but I just go
way back this is and it's a natural
human endeavor this is we've been doing
this for forever
hi I'm Amanda Smith I was asked to speak
about 100k and ten first of all I'm from
Penn State's Center for Science in the
schools and I'm the representative for
the university and 100k and ten if
you're not aware of it is an or national
organization that has about two hundred
and fifty members of it so far and
they're always growing but they have a
really nice structure where they've
divided into project teams to tackle
varying issues across STEM education and
outreach and Tahlia the CEO was supposed
to be here today but couldn't be but if
you'd like to find out more information
I'm always happy to share it on the
slack Channel and give you more
information but the structure is really
nice because it can't just take one
person to manage all of it it's going to
take a village and how they've divided
project teams has been really really
nice and they've spent a lot of time
mapping out the Grand Challenges in STEM
education and it's it's public now and
it's called I believe it's called like
Grand Challenges 100 K and ten org but
they're really looking at all the issues
of getting highly qualified over a
hundred thousand qualified STEM ready
educators by the next ten years and so
2022 is the date that they're up and
they were originally funded by the Obama
administration and the Clinton
initiative also funds them heavily as
well but I think it's a definitely a
great organization to look at as far as
structure and how we might be able to
fold in and to learn more about those
Grand Challenges and maybe where does
science outreach also fold into that
dynamic as well
you